all right so it's 421 so we were
officially a minute late so I can start
so uh how's everyone doing today are
your brains pulsating with painful
knowledge that's doing other Puttock
word things that I can't come up with
off the top of my head everyone
everyone's brain full well I'm sorry but
uh there's always room for webassembly
so so this is my talk what's old is new
again an introduction and webassembly I
actually picked this picture of a an old
adding machine on purpose because it's
old and but it's kind of the you know
adding and adding machines kind of the
foundation of a lot of computing it's
mechanical but it's it's you know it's a
it's a related piece of technology
around the progression of making numbers
do our bidding with electronics so I I
just thought and that looks kind of cool
so my name is guy Royce and the most
important thing you need to know about
me is that I am NOT an expert on
webassembly I'm a fan of webassembly
and so I have done stuff with it
explored how it works so that I as a
developer I can use it and understand it
at a lower level there's a lot of deeper
knowledge about it that I'm not gonna
have I actually gave this talk last week
and someone came up afterwards and said
yeah hi I'm on the web assembly working
committee and I felt really stupid but
he just come up to thank me for you know
talking about web assembly because it's
it's an important topic to him I mean
obviously it would be right and so I'm
coming at this as a developer and as a
fan and I've made it do things and I
understand how it works but there's you
know I hear conflicting information
some people like well it's faster and
then I was like well actually it's not
faster yet but it will be faster and
it's like well but isn't this blazer
it's like well this is the thing Blazers
built on top of so this is you know it's
a web stump we talk from a fan and my
goal is to try and get underneath it to
get to the fundamental level of what web
assembly does and so that you can
build on top of that and build on top of
that understand what it's really doing
so I work for data data robot as a
developer evangelist so they pay me to
come out to events like this and give
talks on things that aren't our product
at all in exchange for me saying that
you should check us out and we're hiring
so enough of that if you want to follow
me on Twitter there I am I'm at guy
Royce on Twitter honestly if you just
type guy Royce into Google I'm like the
only person with this name on the planet
if you spell my last name wrong it will
still find me so so if you want to
follow me I have my phone in airplane
mode so feel free to say mean things for
the next hour after that say nice things
so I'll start with the the question the
unimaginative what is web assembly so
obviously everyone in this room is
probably heard of web assembly if not
for the very reason that they read it on
the on the pamphlet but how many have
are familiar with web assembly played
with it
who's see in what context have you guys
done it feel like what blazer some
people have done some blazer stuff what
about through rust okay two of you oh
three of ya
good good who feels like they really
understand what web assembly is that's
awesome I meant to start this talk out
by saying that I'm a complete expert and
you should listen to everything I say so
I like my definition of web assembly
it's 50% web and 50% assembly you might
be looking at this and thinking guys
kind of old to be a spongebob fan but I
have children so but it's kind of what
it is right there's the web aspect and
there's the assembly aspect and those
are the really the two pieces that make
it up
and it's assembly language for the web
and so I thought I'd talk about the web
piece first because a web assembly like
any technology is trying to solve a
problem right and the problem that web
assembly is trying to solve is it's got
a few facets to it but the biggest part
of it is what the hell JavaScript right
how many of you are JavaScript
programmers everyone should raise their
hand right how many of you go home at
night and cry I don't cry I drink but to
each their own but I mean you know
javascript is a challenge to language so
we say and I like JavaScript I like it
on ironically I run it a lot of people
it's like well let's get rid of
JavaScript will do typescript and I'm
like no I don't want to be a Java
programmer anymore
now everyone leaves but I actually do
like JavaScript as a language I like it
it's dynamic I like the way the closures
work it's I enjoy it as a language but
it's got some weird corners so for
example array is equal to not array
that's true right not a number triple
equals not a number is false I'm pretty
sure that's not the definition of false
I like that the number of min value is
greater than zero I wish that was true
of my bank account
[Music]
if you parse int the word firetruck it
returns not a number which is completely
true fire trucks are not numbers it was
also the only word I could think of that
started with an F and ended in those
letters it's like a joke grenade yeah
but if you do fire truck with a comma 16
on the end of it all of a sudden that's
worth 15 because JavaScript actually
it's it's seam F in this thing that's
hex is what's happening but that's kind
of goofy behavior I like the console dot
log call that call duck call duck call
that call that apply because every
function has a call function on it and
so you can just chain them as many times
as you want to want to do any does the
same thing JavaScript weird math dot min
is greater than math dot max that
returns true Java scripts got some weird
corners and you know I always felt like
we could cut JavaScript a little bit of
slack because the guy who created it did
it in like a week and you know I
couldn't write a language in a week and
so I mean actually his achievements
fairly impressive but it had some weird
edge cases and so a part of the problem
that webassembly can solve is hey Java
scripts weird maybe I could do something
else other than JavaScript because I'm
in a browser right the nice thing about
programming in the browser is is that I
can use any language I want as long as
it's JavaScript and I know what you're
thinking and you're thinking well I can
do typescript I can do I can do es6 and
I can transpile and I can do all this
stuff and I can use Elm if I want
there's a lot of languages there's a
remember CoffeeScript but that was
popular for a couple years there there's
a lot of options and that's true you can
but at the end of the day there's still
just JavaScript so you're transpiling
that into javascript and so your errors
are gonna be in JavaScript you can't get
away without knowing the JavaScript even
if you're building in a language of
trans files to it it's it's always going
to be there
and you know it's easy to build a modern
JavaScript application using something
some more advanced version of Java
scripts that you want to use like es6
you know on Internet Explorer 6 you set
up this easy environment with all these
tools and you're good to go alright and
this is just sort of a list of tools
some of them are a little dated honestly
but now actually setting up these
JavaScript environments is kind of a
pain in the butt and I think I think
it's kind of funny that the picture I
selected with all these tools on it so
many of them are knives it's like I'm
there's some subtle subconscious thing
going on there maybe I actually hate
JavaScript but yes setting up these
environments are kind of complicated
so that's one of the pain points but
there's actually even a more fundamental
thing with JavaScript and just the way
the browser works because it's an
interpreted language I've got to take
that that javascript file and download
it from the internet
that takes time now I can minify it and
help reduce that time you know reduce
that download time and that can help but
then I've got a tokenize it I got to
turn it into a bunch of tokens and I got
to take those tokens and then parse them
to build it in you know the syntax tree
and then once I have that syntax tree I
can execute that syntax tree and so I've
got to go through that compilation
process every single time I go to run
that JavaScript code and that's time
consuming and well wouldn't be nice if
we could compile the code for our
browser instead of interpreting it so
that we could do that parsing and we
could do that that lexing before and not
have to do it again if we could do some
sort of compilation of our code for our
browser above our JavaScript and you
know that would be that would be a
silver bullet
this jokes funny in America
it's a terrible American beer someone
told me they knew what it was here they
lied to me and the joke's on me but uh
that would be a total solution to that
problem right I could solve the problem
of JavaScript because I wouldn't have to
use JavaScript I could compile some
other language to something that could
run in the browser and it would be
compiled and so it would perform better
and the tooling would be whatever the
tooling is appropriate to that platform
which honestly could be worse than what
we have in JavaScript but it could also
be better and you could just use all
these different you know your front-end
code could be written in the same
language as your back-end code and it
wouldn't have to be JavaScript that'd be
kind of amazing wouldn't it I think it
would be and that's what assembly is
that is cake code compile it to a binary
target that you can end use from browser
so I thought it might be worthwhile to
talk a little bit about how
microprocessors work not in excruciating
detail but how assembly language or
machine could work works because a lot
of people haven't done this so I'm gonna
be 47 in March and I'm young for having
done any kind of work in assembly at all
all right how many people have been paid
to write code in assembly language yeah
exactly
right and some of you may have studied
this in college and not looked at it
since and so I thought and some of you
may be just newer to the field and
haven't looked at it at all so I thought
a review of how this stuff works would
be worthwhile so we all know that
computers only talk in ones and zeroes
and that's like the thing we tell our
kids about computers when they're fought
you know five but it's true
on the right here I've got some machine
code in binary this is actual machine
code it does do stuff on a 6502
microprocessor which was the one used in
the Apple to ease in the Commodore 64's
and it takes those and those are there's
series of instructions that say things
like take this value from this register
and put it on
the accumulator and take this value here
and add it to this other value here in
memory and all these operations that do
things and you know these ones and zeros
you know they're basically 5 volts and 0
volts go through that microprocessor
triggering different patterns and gates
and it all does stuff and gives you
output it's it's actually kind of
amazing that it all works but this
binary code here that we're looking at
is really hard to read but it is real
code and so to make it a little easier
to read maybe we've represented as
hexadecimal here so on the on the Left
we've got that binary code on the right
I've got an arbitrary memory address
starting at 200 hex and then I've got
just bytes we're representing that code
it's a little easier to read it's a
little more human-friendly but only
barely I mean what's a zero right who
knows right
what's the zero zero after it and so but
this is the language that the machine
the microprocessor actually understands
and so but humans don't understand it
and so we came up with this thing called
assembly language yeah
and so yeah this is this is 6502
assembly language and if you look in
here you can see like for example the
first one has load the Y ik register
with the value of zero zero so stores
one byte so a zero means load Y a two is
load X with zero zero and these are just
these are these are more meaningful
mnemonics like here we got jump and then
we got loop there's a label this ties up
to this label over here if you look on
the code over here jump is for C and
then we want to jump to this spot so
that's 207 and you can see here the
little endian notation because the
second byte is the less significant
number or the big endian big endian i
said that back fencepost there is sorry
folks but so you can see that you know
that byte order is in not
order the us humans would expect to see
it and but these all translate to these
meaningful things and so this is a more
meaningful way to program it's still
really low level
this is a double nested loop that's all
it does I think I did write this code in
fact it's the first assembly language
program may ever wrote I still had it
written on a piece of paper at my house
and I had my son take a picture of it
and send it to me at work so I could put
it in this talk and I literally wrote
the code in assembly by hand on the left
looked up the opcodes on a piece of
paper and translated it over in hex and
then I was doing this on a
microprocessor board and there was a hex
keypad and a bunch of seven segment
displays and when that thing booted it
would ask you what address to start
executing and there was one of the
addresses was the loader address you
know then let me load a program in so I
trained I I compiled this I assembled it
by hand and then I put all the hex
digits in and when it was done it looped
and called some function called scan
which was on a ROM I don't remember what
raka scan did but I have the code still
so this is actual code that I wrote back
in the 80s as a teenager and this was
used to be how people would create a
right to assembly language I think
they'd code on paper and trans pilot
people started making assemblers to make
this easier but it turns out of Hanoi
Minh hated them as a fun fact he said it
was a waste of a valuable scientific
computing instrument to use it to do
clerical work which i think is really
funny because what do you use your
computer for right isn't that like
everything we do in our career is create
as clerical work I worked for an
insurance company for 12 years it's all
clerical work that's that's actually the
job and so really man he missed this one
but he wasn't a fan he actually yelled
at some of his grad students because
they had created an assembler and he
felt like that was a waste of resources
so
dude by hand of course Assembly's hard
to read too and so things like see
happened and so here we've got some C
code which is doing the same thing
except it's a lot more readable and we
probably many of us here have done C if
you haven't done C we'll just pretend
that's Java and because it doesn't look
any different I'm sorry did I say job I
meant c-sharp I'm sorry I'm in
JavaScript but yeah so we started
writing C code and then it would compile
and parse all that stuff and give us
that same binary and the world was great
programming was getting easier and
easier but we're still a little these
machine targeted binaries and so you
could run it on your 6502 microprocessor
but there's a problem with this which is
that the only processor in the world was
not the 6502 microprocessor there's a
lot of micro processors and they all
have different instruction sets and some
of the more big endian and some of them
were little endian and some of them had
different registers and just different
mechanisms they're just they're
different machines built by different
engineers for different reasons the way
they did it and so you'd have to write
your code at C and then compile it to
one processor and another processor and
another processor you can just compile
it once and use it in one place you
could compile it to a lower processor
and a family and then it would run on
more machines but the performance
wouldn't be as good and so you saw this
on the Intel stuff where you could
compile something that would run on an
until 80 86 and that would run on a 286
and a 386 and a 46 but it wouldn't take
advantage of the capabilities of that
microprocessor to the fullest extent and
so it was a bit of a problem and you'd
have to deliver different versions of
your binaries to different customers and
so someone came up with a brilliant idea
to solve that problem
that's the virtual microprocessor or the
virtual machine
I personally first saw this for Java I
know the idea predates it but I don't
know the details
my introduction to this idea was Java
that's probably true for a lot of us in
here if not that it might be the the
common language runtime on dotnet same
you know who stole the idea from Java
who stole from whoever did it before but
the idea here is is that like all
software problems it can be solved with
a layer of abstraction right
this virtual microprocessor is a layer
of abstraction on top of a physical
microprocessor and so it's the same idea
but instead of having all these programs
compiled to virtual to specific
processors you have the virtual machine
for each of the processors or families
of processors and then you just write
your code in something that virtual
machine understands and so this case now
that's definitely Java code on the Left
right here because it's gonna run on the
JVM here and if you look here you'll say
see the first four bytes are say cafe
babe every Java binary every class file
starts with that and that solves a lot
of problems webassembly
is exactly the same idea but in the
browser so I can write my code in a
language I want I can compile it to a
byte code that isn't interpreted by a
virtual machine that is running in the
browser so it's exactly the same idea
but in the browser now I'll wait a
second I see someone taking a picture
before I advance the slides so but
that's what web assembly is it's the
same idea as what's all this new again
right it's worthwhile to get a little
deeper into how web assembly works
because this has all been sort of like
review and sort of a history of how
these things work but at some point you
got to get down to actual implementation
like I'm gonna have some file on a
computer that needs to be served up
somewhere and so this gives you an idea
of how wasm how
simply fits into your applications so
we've got on in here with you get our
big yellow browser here and on the Left
we've got our classic triumvirate of web
frame web application technology we've
got our CSS we've got our HTML we've got
our JavaScript they're just files that
we download and they interact with the
DOM and do all sorts of things the web
assembly binary that you have is just
another file that your web page can
download or your JavaScript usually well
specifically you can't embed it into the
HTML yet that I know of you have to
explicitly get it from JavaScript but
it's just another file it's it up it
served up just like an image or a JSON a
JavaScript file and these arrows here
are significant so our JavaScript as we
know can interact with the Dom with the
HTML and it can also interact with the
web assembly module so when you
instantiate one of these things it's got
the exposés functions that JavaScript
can consume and the web assembly module
can talk to JavaScript you will note
that there is not an arrow between the
web assembly module and HTML obviously I
did that on purpose that's because the
web assembly doesn't have the capability
to talk to the Dom it is a pure machine
it's it's a pure binary target it
doesn't know about the Dom or anything
of the sort you can call JavaScript
functions it's handed but it can't and
it can and those can manipulate the Dom
so you can build bridges but the bridges
aren't built in
just a moment
so this is kind of saying something I
said already they just toasted with
other web content they're just files on
a on a web server
mention the content type here needs to
be application wasm I think Safari cares
about this other ones don't care as much
it just depends on how picky the the
implementation is and we instantiate
them from JavaScript so if you look here
at this code on the bottom you've got a
I'm using fetch to fetch the file name
and that returns a promise and so it
gives me a response the response has an
array buffer I get the bytes out of that
array buffer and then the byte array
goes into web assembly doesn't Stan she
ate there is a way to shortcut this
where you can do a streaming version of
it where you can download them and
process the bytes at the same time and
that's more efficient but I found that
it was a little flaky when I did it on
Safari
but it worked fine in Chrome and Firefox
and I don't know about edge but so I did
it I did it the more the way that worked
everywhere
once that instantiates done it returns a
promise that then returns the module the
web assembly module and then you can
make use of that module so this is and
this is this is a very complicated way
of calling new admittedly but it's where
the technology is at right now it's
worth noting that this is version 1.0
and so this is a lot of this is very
green and so this is a first cut
something that has a lot of potential
now how many of you were around when the
JVM was first released and coding I
assume you are all live remember how it
was really slow and everyone's like this
is going nowhere it's slow it's like
well but speed and performance wasn't
really its key feature and they solved
the performance problem the key feature
here is not how easy it is to new to
instantiate these things it's that we've
got something that can run multiple
languages in the browser the tooling to
make this easier will common is coming
so the modules themselves are actually
really easy to use they literally just
expose functions and you literally just
call them
and so here we're you know I could say
module de instance that exports fizzbuzz
and pass in 15 and it returns a value
his buzz you'd think that except in the
next slide I'm going to tell you that
webassembly doesn't support strings yeah
or enums webOS Emily only deals with
with numbers actually which is kind of
what microprocessors do right they don't
know what strings are see knows what a
string is but a microprocessor doesn't
know what strings are it knows a raise
of it doesn't even know arrays it just
knows memory and so there's no native
string implementation for web assembly
which seems incredibly constraining but
your your language it's on top of that
will provide those abstractions so here
we've got calculate area returning the
thing and they just you just call them
you just call the functions that's all
there is to it you can also pass in
functions for them the web assembly
modules to call you back on so here
you've got this doubly nested object
where it's it you know imports imports
and then your your functions and when
you instantiate there if you look down
slide here we pass that imports object
in as well and now that's a function
that's that web assembly module will
have access to and it can call to notify
you of things this would be if you
wanted to have your web assembly module
interact with the Dom you'd write
functions that would allow it to
interact with the Dom and pass them in
this in this function or if you wanted
your web assembly module interact with a
network be a similar sort of thing
because again there's no networking API
inside of the web assembly just like
there's no Dom it's completely samp
it's it's very sandboxed but then when
you know for example if you call
fizzbuzz callback presumably the FISMA
with callback actually does a callback
and then this function would would get
called
I mentioned functions can only take
numbers there is a way to get around to
this you can define shared memory blocks
and pass them in along with the imports
and so in here I'm creating webassembly
dot memory module giving an initial size
of 10 pages
so that's 640k each page is 64 K so and
I thought I'd take a page from Bill
Gates and assume that we would never
need more than 640 K of memory in an
application and web assembly and so I
set it to 10 so it will grow on its own
so if it needs to get bigger it will and
then that shared memory is can be used
as a as an array as an array of bytes
and then you can just go into that array
of bytes and look at them and change
them and the web sent from JavaScript or
from web assembly and so this is a way
of passing more complex data structures
back and forth not really passing them
you're just like hey look over there hey
yeah it's over there and you can do this
with strings this is how you can do
strings so you put a utf-8 encoded
string into a memory location and then
if web assembly needs to return a string
it returns to the memory location it
returns the B address within that that
block of memory and so it is very C like
they were returning pointers right we're
returning pointers to that string and so
it's very good it's kind of fun it's it
I feel like that like I'm a young
programmer again sometimes when I'm
doing this stuff but yes you can put any
kind of data and you want there but keep
in mind and web assembly you can really
only manipulate numbers and so complex
structures are gonna be hard so you know
you're not gonna sell a bunch of JSON in
there you're gonna you know that would
be I would not want to write a JSON
parser in webassembly not in webassembly
text format
to create these modules you've got a few
options I just got a couple samples of
code here you've got a unit from C and
so this is a basic visible calculator
for C you'll note this for phys I
returned negative 1 for buzz that
returned negative 2 and for fizzes they
returned negative 3 because I can't
return strings easily and so I went
ahead and just use numbers here instead
but this is a basic implementation of
this buzz you can compile this to web
assemble and I have in the past and and
use it now here's the same code in rust
similar idea just it's rust code instead
and I actually have rust working on my
macbook and so I'll show that to you in
a moment
but before we do that I want to show you
the web assembly text format because
I've got two demos and depending on time
I may cut one of them short one demo is
a simple little app I built which
computes fizzbuzz and you can compute it
using just pure JavaScript you can
compute it from rust and you can compute
it from a web assembly text format and I
have created blasts and files for two of
those three and then you can choose the
ones you want here is the hard way that
doesn't look anything like the other
ones so in webassembly you define a
module that's the unit of azam as a web
assembly module you list all the
functions you want to export and the
value in quotes there is the name of the
function from Java scripts point of view
and the value with the dollar sign in
front of it is just a simple pointing to
this guy here we define a function it
takes parameter dollar a parameter
dollar B and they're both 32-bit
integers and it has a result of a 32-bit
integer and then and then you've got the
body of the function here where we get
the two values we passed in and we add
them and in a traditional machine that
I'm familiar with I have
and did not do a lot of assembly
language but on the 6502 we had these
registers right we're saying load this
into the X register and add this to the
accumulator and that kind of stuff
web assembly doesn't work like that it's
stack based so when I come into the add
function my stack is empty and then I
call get local and that gets the dollar
a value which I put a little comment
there to say is arbitrarily a five and
get local takes it from the parameter
and pushes it on the stack and then get
local B takes the next value and pushes
it on the stack and now we get two
values on our stack we call add an add
will pop off the 10 pop off the 5 add
the numbers and push the answer back
onto the stack so this is how it's
working internally and then whatever is
left on the stack at the end is the
return value if you have too many things
on the stack or not enough things on the
stack when you return it will throw an
error well it'll just stop it'll say I
can't do this and it'll stop executing
and give you an error that's hard to
figure out because the tooling is not
quite there for debugging yet so that's
kind of how it works internally so for
the quick demo here let me show you that
needs to be bigger
that's some of the code here so I've got
this little app here where you can enter
a fizzbuzz value so if I put in like two
and is buzz it says two because two is
the answer is everyone familiar with is
buzz so it's it's a does everyone know
that it's a drinking game you didn't
okay you're my new friend
so uh fizzbuzz was originally a drinking
game the idea was you sat around a table
and you you counted and you know and
then the rules for fizzbuzz or if it's a
multiple of three you safe is it's a
multiple five you say buzz and it's a
multiple of both you say fizzbuzz but if
he got it wrong you had to take a drink
which then led to you getting it wrong
more like all good drinking games right
and so you know it's one two fizz for
buzz fizz seven eight is buzz and I'm
not drinking it I'm doing it wrong yeah
yeah I mean maybe when you play fizzbuzz
you need to prime the pump and give
everyone a couple shots first you know
it sounds like a great way to play
fizzbuzz so you know so this is
executing my JavaScript code which is
just it's not webassembly it's
JavaScript I've got a rust version that
I compiled here and if I put in say a
three there click the button and it
shows fizz now if we look at the console
here
if you can see this I've got a callback
here so if I click this here you see
fizzbuzz callback as negative one so I'm
returning a negative one as a number
because again webassembly doesn't want
to do strings easily I do have a version
where I implement strings and I got a
link to it at the end you guys can check
it out later
it took me two days to build fizzbuzz
with it so I don't recommend doing it
the hard way yourself but you're welcome
to learn from my mistakes
but this is calling the rust version and
in webassembly text format we can also
call this and see buzz returns on - - -
and the code for all this is right here
so if we look at fizzbuzz dot rust this
is the same code we had there you'll
notice had in the slides but you'll
notice it calls the callback here and
there's an unsafe or after and that's
because we're leaving the safe space
that rust creates for us and then I've
defined my callback here as an extern
and so that allows it to work and if we
look at my build is H this is this is
all out on github so you guys can look
at it at your leisure but you can go
ahead and build this yourself there's
some notes in there on the things you
need to know to get it working but and
I'm not a rust expert by any measure but
I was able to get this to work I'm the
web assembly modules that Russ is
creating for me are huge and I think
it's because all the debug symbols are
getting built in there and I'm I don't
know enough about Russ to take those out
but if I go here to the command line
let's control see this background is and
then I can go into rust and if I just
use flush build that SH and then I bring
it back up again
is that readable enough with the black
background blacks usually hard to see in
these settings here and I didn't change
my prom
that fizzbuzz that Wasden is now got a
timestamp that's more now-ish and if i
go out and refresh the hard refresh this
and run the rust version it's executing
that version and again you can check
this code out online on github so the
webassembly text version of fizzbuzz is
defined right here and so here's a
bigger program to take a look at so I've
got my module I'm exporting fizzbuzz
binding to a function I'm importing
fizzbuzz callback and giving it a name
that I can call and I'm setting the
arguments is expecting and then here is
that stack based computing I'm shoving
and under the stack I'm shoving 15 onto
the stack and I have a little function I
wrote it's private it's an internal
called is multiple and is multiple gets
the two values and puts them on the
stack does a modulus remainder unsigned
and then says which pops these does the
division shoves the value back on and
then equals zero looks at what's on the
stack and says is it zero well then it's
zero is it not zero well I got that
backwards if it's zero in sets of 1
otherwise it sets it to zero so it's
it's making it boolean and then in here
the if statement says well if what's on
the stack is zero or is 1 this is true
so pop that shove my hard-coded value on
to the stack call callback shove it on
to the stack again and return and it's
following in that process and so this is
a lot of code for fizzbuzz so and then
we go down to 5 and 3 and then if it's
neither of those when we return the
heart and we return what we were handed
and so what I'm going to do and may that
demo gods have mercy on my soul
as I am going to live code a fizzbuzz
implementation test deriving it from
jasmine and in webassembly text format
so yeah you got like this is gonna be
great we're gonna watch a crash and burn
so I feel like I need to get talcum
powder on my hands okay so I have here a
little Jasmine test runner set up
already see fizzbuzz spec is completely
empty I've got a spec helper whose sole
purpose and life is to not randomize my
tests because when they move around for
a demo it's confusing I've got a little
wasm helper that I wrote here that loads
a webassembly module and this should
look like familiar code
it's the code I've shown on the slides
already and so uh let's begin so we
don't need this guy but we do need to
describe his buzz and I'm gonna use the
es6 style syntax and then I'm before
each I'm gonna need a I'm gonna need one
of those need my webassembly module and
so load wasm and i'm gonna load fizzbuzz
wasm and then that's going to give me
the module and I'm saying this subject
equals module and then
I called done and so if you're not
familiar with jasmine done that's how
you do a synchronous testing in Jasmine
so it'll wait until done is called
before it starts running all the other
tests it's I don't know why it always
does that I do not want an interface it
returns one for returns the handed the
past was two passed in number and I was
an agile coach in a previous life and so
I'm a TDD purist so that's why I'm
writing my tests first so expect this
subject dot fizzbuzz value one to be the
one makes sense is that big enough for
people in the back I can make it a
little bigger if we need to okay so
let's run our tests and see if it fails
for the expected reason that's okay so
it hangs and the reasons hanging is
because it can't find the module yes see
we've got a timeout async callback was
not booked within 500 milliseconds that
seems like it was about five seconds so
let's go ahead and create a wack file
how many people have seen the Gary
Bernhardt video with the the JavaScript
yeah I always think of that when I'm
doing web assembly this buzz doe at
there's actually a web assembly
something toolkit that's called wabbit I
can't run what the B stands for off the
top of my head now but okay module and
then we need to export said indent that
fizzbuzz and it was funk dollar fizzbuzz
and then funk dollar fizzbuzz per am
dollar n i 32 the result i 32 and so
right now all we need to do is say i 32
Const 1 because we're going to return a
hard coded 1 i should be able to right
click on this I'm using a tool in a
extension for a visual studio code which
is the web assembly I don't remember the
name of it but it sits in my next slide
that allows me to save web assembly
files to assemble them right from the
IDE the text editor which is super
useful so you see it created a waggon
file here if I click on it it'll say
that's binary but there's an option to
show web assembly and so that's the
disassembled code of the code I just
assembled so it's very similar but not
exactly the same so let's see if that
works
hooray it works
[Applause]
that's way too soon okay so we need to
create another failing test here returns
other passed in numbers so let's pass in
a to I'm expect to get a two back that's
gonna should complain that expected one
to be two and then in our implementation
here what we need to do instead is call
get local dollar n so now it will return
whatever you hand it we've created echo
and if I save this as webassembly
and rerun my tests now it handles all
sorts of numbers so let's do something a
little more interesting well I'm going
to split down and split this down so we
can see both of these at the same time I
think that would maybe a little better
it returns fizz actually is gonna return
negative one this is just copy that
returns negative one for multiples of
three so if it passes in a three I
should get negative one right
expected three to be negative one that's
the expected error so let's go into here
and say we we need to do a modulus opera
we need to do a comparison and so so
we'll get and and then we'll say I
thirty-two EQ and say hang on I'm
missing a step here I thirty-two Const 3
so he shoved the value passed into the
stack it's on the stack three is on top
of that on the stack will call equals
which will say are these two things on
the stack equal or not we'll push in a
true or false then we can say if an end
and then then return and we want to say
I thirty-two Const minus one otherwise
once the I get local dollar n so what
that's going to do is it's going to take
the local on the cost so we're gonna do
that comparison if that's true we're
gonna set it to minus one in return
otherwise our stacks still empty and so
we need to take our local value and put
back on there that makes sense okay good
it made sense to me let me save that off
replace
hooray now I'm starting to feel a little
smarter by the way I would not recommend
doing this for actual production code
god this language it's a very verbose
it's cool that it exists and we can do
this but I would not want to do this day
in and day out so let's go ahead and say
it returns -1 for other multiples of 3
we pass in a 6
that'll fail for the expected reason and
instead of doing this we need to say I
32 to ram underscore you calculate the
remainder and then we can say equals
zero what's it on line seven down here
oh I got it yeah thank you
it's like massive pair program that
people say pair programming doesn't work
[Laughter]
it's amenable I'm gonna blame my
keyboard because only a poor craftsman
blames his tools so let's go ahead and
save this and actually that little
assembler will show you error so they
would have caught it but thank you so
now it's working for other multiples of
three and then you can imagine how this
turns into five and fifteen but I did
want to show another thing here and
we'll finish it out but this is kind of
heavy syntax right I mean your line is
loading a thing under the stack there's
actually a mechanism where you can use s
expressions to make this more readable
and so I can take this guy here and wrap
him in parenthesis and this guy here and
wrap him in parenthesis oops put those
on one line
and rap then in parentheses and that's
starting to look like a function call so
that's a little more of an intuitive
syntax and so that should assemble
properly you know let's make sure this
still works
it still works you can do the same thing
with the if statement we say if I 32 dot
equals Z then do stuff end it we don't
need that anymore
and then we can say return like that so
now it's starting to look like more
familiar programming and then just for
completeness sake we can do this as well
yeah yeah it's that's really funny
actually I hadn't thought about that but
I don't have a good answer yeah so that
should still work oh I broke something
Oh yep yep it's it's inverting us
there we go
and yeah so we could very easily then do
we'll do it really quick here I will
cheat and write all my tests at once
even though the purist in me is dying a
little bit on the inside so - - and then
returns - - for other multiples of 5 and
we set that to 10 and that de - - and
then let's go ahead and do the whole
shebang here turns - 3 for multiples of
3 and 5 nice 3 for other multiples of 3
and 5 pass in 15 pass in 30 passin 3 or
negative 3 here and then if we run these
we should see lots of failures 4 of them
and then we can pretty easily just take
this code here and I don't always reuse
code but when I do I copy and paste
that's right
oops you saw it go wrong and they make
this 15 I'm deliberately doing this in
the right order so they don't have to
deal with that save as well assembly
binary
it did not complain and it all passes so
I thank you
[Applause]
now I feel smart so that is that's the
webassembly text format achievement
unlocked so I mentioned there were some
links to articles here this is a lot of
the stuff that I looked at when I was
researching this to put this talk
together the Mozilla developer Network
Sartre achill czar fantastic their
stuffs just fantastic in general you
should be using if you're doing any
JavaScript at all you should be using
the Mozilla developer Network
webassembly dot org is where the
standard lives was not the most
consumable thing for some of the text
format stuff it was sort of written in a
hey here's how you would write a
compiler sort of fashion not a here's
how we would program it in this on a
daily basis because no one should be
programming in this in a daily basis the
web assembly binary toolkit is a
command-line tool for building
assemblers and disassemblers of web
assemblies code the web assembly toolkit
for Visual Studio code is what I was
using in this talk super useful got
syntax highlighting - Russ got building
supports in scriptum is a tool that will
take your C code and we'll build the
HTML and the CSS and the JavaScript
bridges and the web assembly modules and
turn your application into a web app
it's pretty neat that's I'm told that's
what Blazers built on top of well
there's a whole bunch of other languages
that are supported out there
awesome wasm has a bunch of cool stuff
that's out there and this is all on my
github account so that the links are
active there so check it out why some
Explorer is fun because it lets you just
copy and paste C code and generate a
wizened file from that and web assembly
studio is actually a web-based IDE for
this stuff so they're all fun and worth
checking out
and there's the github links I promised
there's internal web assembly which is
this talk these slides and the code of
the the app that I showed you earlier is
all right there the super complicated
implementation of fizzbuzz that I did
for web assembly with full Model View
controller and and everything
over-engineered fizzbuzz for the web in
webassembly
took me two days to put together that's
there i had to write to do that I had to
write integer 2 alpha ITA because I had
to turn an integer into a number or into
a string like oh it's like C all over
again I'm having write this a little
level stuff so a lot of interesting
tidbits in there and a lot more syntax
to make a little more accessible so
that's worth checking out and yeah
that's pretty much all I've got I've got
three minutes so I could take a question
or two if anyone's got any questions but
I only take easy questions so sorry know
what you go ahead
yeah so the question is is in some of
the earlier samples I was showing a
callback mechanism and is that something
you would use for a synchronicity not
specifically it is the short answer
it's just the way that webassembly can
call into javascript and so I just
trying to show how that worked in that
sample code more than anything there
really isn't that I'm aware of any kind
of threading model going on there I mean
it's JavaScript there really wasn't a
threading model in there anyhow if you
wanted to do some sort of a
synchronicity you'd probably I don't I
don't know that you can do that in web
assembly I think that's something that
have to happen outside so you call some
function the from whether somebody's
brought in
it does something asynchronous it's just
going to return that asynchronous
handler would probably have to call back
into the web assembly module lead-pipe
do all that in JavaScript so I haven't
you tried that that's a really
interesting question
so yes sir
so the question is does web simply have
legs yet and if so what would we use it
for in the future I think it will have
legs I think they're short and stubby
right now people are using it to build
production things I mean that's what
blazer is it's built on top of this for
the type of low level stuff there's a
lot of inconsistency in the ways
different people are implementing it so
it's new thoughts people are trying lots
of things personally I probably wouldn't
put any production apps on this simply
because it's still being it's still
shaking out I think it has some enormous
potential for my pet thing that I want
to use it for is I want to embed machine
learning models into web assembly
modules so I can do machine learning in
the browser so I could build models on
some you know back-end service I do work
for data robot and and embed those into
the browser for future consumption so I
think that's one particularly cool
application that just that I think would
be neat but there's like all like all
this sort of stuff there's all these
cool applications that someone is going
to think of that I'll never think of and
but it's an enabling technology to allow
us to find that stuff so you had a
question okay well I've got one minute
left so I think I'm just gonna say
thanks for coming out again this is me
feel free to tweet at me check out data
robot please and yeah that's all I got
so thanks a lot
[Applause]